This lecture is about a mixture of
unigram language models.
In this lecture we will continue
discussing probabilistic topic models.
In particular, we're going to introduce
a mixture of unigram language models.
This is a slide that you have seen
earlier where we talked about how to
get rid of the background words that
we have on top of estimated language
model for one document.
So if you want to solve the problem.
It will be useful to think about why we
end up having this problem.
Well, this is obviously because these
words are very frequent in our data and
we are using a maximum likelihood
estimate and then the estimator
obviously would have to assign high
probabilities for these words in order
to maximize the likelihood.
So in order to get rid of them, that
would mean we have to do something
different here.
In particular, we have to say that this
distribution doesn't have to explain
all the words in the text data, or
we're going to say these common words
should not be explained by this
distribution.
So one natural way to solve the problem
is to think about using another
distribution to account for just these
common words.
This way the two distributions can be
mixed together to generate the text
data and will let the other model which
we called background topic model to
generate the common words.
This way our target is the topic theta
here would be only generating the content words
that characterize the content of the
document.
So how does this work?
It's just a small modification of the
previous set up where we have just one
distribution.
Since we now have two distributions, we
have to decide which distribution to
use when we generate the word, but
each word will still be sampled from one
of the two distributions, right?
So text data is still generating the
same way.
Namely, we're going to generate a one
word at each time.
An eventually we generated a lot of
words.
When we generate the word, however,
we're going to 1st decide which of the
two distributions to use, and this is
controlled by
another probability: probability of
theta sub D and probability of
theta sub B here.
So this is the probability of selecting
the topic word distribution.
This is the probability of selecting
the background word distribution
denoted by Theta sub B.
Now in this case I just give example
where we can set both to .5.
So if you can do basically flip a coin
a fair coin to decide which one to use.
But in general these probabilities
don't have to be equal, so you might
bias towards using one topic more than
the other.
So now the process of generating a
word would be the first to flip a coin
based on these probabilities of
choosing each model and if.
Let's say the coin shows up as head,
which means we're going to use the
topic word distribution.
Then we're going to use this word
distribution to generate a word.
Otherwise we might be going through
this path.
And we're going to use the background
word distribution to generate the word.
So in such a case we have a model that
has some uncertainty associated with
the use of a word distribution.
But we can still think of this as a
model for generating text data and such
a model is called a mixture model.
So now let's see.
In this case, what's the probability of
observing the word w?
Now here I showed some words like "the"
and "text", so as in all cases, once we
set up the model, we're interested in
computing the likelihood function.
The basic question is, so what's the
probability of observing a specific
word here?
Now we know that the word can be
observed from each of the two
distributions, so we have to consider 2
cases.
Therefore it's a sum over these two
The first case is to use the topic
word distribution to generate the
word, and in such a case, then the
probability would be the probability of
Theta sub D, which is the probability
of choosing the model multiplied by the
probability of actually observing the
word from that model.
Both events must happen in order to
observe "the".
We first must have chosen the topic of
and then we also have to actually
have sampled the word "the" from the
distribution and similarly the second
part accounts for a different way of
generating the word from the
background.
Now obviously the probability of text
the same is all similar, right?
So we also consider two ways of
generating text, and each case is a
product of the probability of choosing
a particular word distribution
multiplied by the probability of
observing the word from that
distribution.
Now later you will see this is actually
general form, so you might want to make
sure that you have really understood
this expression here.
And you should convince yourself that
this is indeed the probability of
observing text.
So to summarize, what we observe here,
the probability of a word from a
mixture model is in general a sum over
all different ways of generating the
word.
And in each case it's a product of the
probability of selecting that component
model.
multiplied by the probability of
actually observing the data point from
that component model, and this is
something quite general and you will
see this occurring often later.
So the basic idea of a mixture model is
just to treated these two distributions
together as one model.
So I use the box to bring all these
components together.
So if you view this whole box as one
model, it's just like any other
generative model.
It would just give us the probability
of a word.
But the way that determines this
probability is quite different from
when we have just one distribution.
And this is basically a more
complicated mixture model.
Sorry, more complicated model than just
one distribution, and it's called a
mixture model.
So as I just said, we can treat this as
just a generative model and it's often
useful to think of just the likelihood
function.
The illustration that you have seen
before, which is dimmer now is just the
illustration of this generation model.
So mathematically, this model.
This is nothing but to just define the
following generative model where the
probability of word is assumed to be a
sum over 2 cases of generating the
word.
The form you're seeing now is more
general form than.
what you have seen in the calculation earlier.
I just used a simple w to denote any
word, but you can still see.
This is basically the first sum.
Like
And this sum is due to the fact that
the word can be generating multiple
ways.
Two ways in this case.
At inside sum, each term is a product
again of two terms.
And the two terms are ,first, the
probability of selecting a component
like Theta sub D. Second, the
probability of actually observing the
word from this component model.
And so this is a very general description
of, in fact, all the mixture models.
And I just want to make sure that you
understand this, because this is really
the basis for understanding all kinds
of topic models.
So now once we set up the model and we
can write down the likelihood function
as we see here, the next question is
how can we estimate the parameter or
what to do with the parameters given
the data?
Well, in general we can use some
observed text data to estimate the
model parameters and this mission
would allow us to discover
the interesting knowledge about the
text, so in this case, what do we
discover?
Well, these are represented by our
parameters, and we have two kinds of
parameters.
One is the two word distributions.
Those are two topics and the other is
the coverage of each topic in each.
The coverage of each topic and this is
determined by probability of Theta
sub D.
and probability of Theta sub B.
Note that they sum to one.
Now what's interesting is also to think
about the special cases, like when we
set one of them to one.
What would happen? Well, the other would
be 0, right?
And if you look at the likelihood
function.
It will then degenerate to the special
case of just one distribution right so
you can easily verify that by assuming
one of these two is 1.0 and the other
is 0.
So in this sense, the mixture model is
more general than the previous model
where we have just one distribution and
it can cover that as a special case.
So to summarize, and we talked about
the mixture of two unigram language
models.
And the data we consider here is
just still 1 document.
And the model is a mixture model with
two components: two unigram language
models.
Specifically, Theta sub D which is
intended to denote the topic of
document D and Theta sub B which is
representing a background topic
that we can set to attract the common
words.
Because common words would be assigned
high probabilities in this model.
So the parameters can be collectively
called a Lambda, which I show here
again, and you can again
think about the question about how many
parameters are we talking about
exactly.
This is usually good exercise to do
because it allows you to see the model
index and to have a complete
understanding of what's going on in
this model and we have mixing weights
of course also.
So what is the likelihood function look
like?
It looks very similar to what we had
before, so for the document, first, it's
a product of all the words in the
document exactly the same as before.
The only difference is that inside here
now it's a sum instead of just one,
so you might recall before we just had
this one.
But now we had this sum because of the
mixture model and because of the mixed
model
We also have to introduce the
probability of choosing that particular
component distribution.
And so this is just another way of
writing it again by using a product
over all the unique words in our
vocabulary, instead of having a product
of all the positions in the document
and this form where we look at
different unique words is a convenient
form for computing the maximum
likelihood estimator later.
And the maximum likelihood estimator
is, as usual, just to find the parameters
that would maximize this likelihood
function and the constraints
here, of course, are two kinds.
One is the word probabilities in each
topic must sum to one, the other is the
choice of each topic must sum to one.